- Someone has to say action
or else I'm not gonna talk.
- [Crew Member] Action!
(upbeat music)
- Woo.
Welcome back to "Making it Big."
This is the show where I
take food that people love
and I make giant versions of them.
What am I doing, you might ask.
Well, today we are gonna
be making a giant Kit Kat.
We have some very expensive
Valrhona chocolate.
We've already been
tempering this chocolate
for about 40 minutes with
a method known sous vide.
This is a machine that
keeps water circulating
at a fixed temperature.
This helps the chocolate set its structure
so that it stays shiny, stay snappy,
and if we're gonna make giant Kit Kat,
we might as well do this the right way.
So I want to keep squishing
these bags of chocolate
and giving them a nice massage
and see you guys when
the chocolate's ready.
(upbeat music)
Okay, so this chocolate is now tempered.
I'm drying it off on this towel
because water and
chocolate do not get along.
They hate each other.
So we have two bags,
there's more in the back.
This is a small fraction
of what we're gonna be using today.
Here we go, ooh-hoo.
This is like a chocolate waterfall.
You guys see this (beep)?
Oh, can't say that.
It's okay, post'll censor it.
So we managed to source large
wafers from a secret store.
Might've been a backroom deal.
My philosophy is if you don't want to know
the answer to the question, you don't ask.
Chocolate is our glue, wafer is our paper.
I was never very good
in arts and craft class,
but I will do my best.
Yeah, ooh, ooh, let's go.
We get a smooth layer.
This thing is gonna take a
lot of chocolate, isn't it?
(upbeat jaunty music)
This is quite satisfying.
You get to fill in all
these little cracks.
Damn. All right, this is one.
Next one goes on, line it up. Nice.
Ooh-hoo-hoo. Oh, little chunks.
Wow, it seems like I
have a lot of work to do.
We'll be right back.
Ba-dun-dun-dun-bum-bum.
That's the commercial song.
After some help with the culinary team,
we have 12 wafers that are all stacked up
with quite a staggering
amount of chocolate.
I have one large knife.
I have one ruler.
Whole thing's around 18 inches,
so maybe divide that by six.
Pull up the woman with the numbers
doing the meme numbers here.
Straight-ish down with
a little bit of rocking.
(wafers crunching)
Woo! That's cool.
Here we go, steady hand.
(wafers crunching)
Woo, one, two, three,
four, five, six bricks.
Oh, you know like in the music videos
when the rappers hold up
like the money to their ear
and they're just like.
I have bands and stacks.
I have Gs and racks.
Gotta get the money 'cause
I'm fly like a honey.
I'm slangin' them bricks.
I think that means something else though.
I'm gonna get so much (beep) for this.
(upbeat music)
This is a large Pullman loaf
pan used for bread making
that happens to be in the perfect size
for those Kit Kat signature ingots.
You know when you guys open a Kit Kat
and you see the words Kit
Kat on the bar itself?
Well, this is my show.
I'm going to put my name.
We have acetate strips, commonly
used in baking or pastry
to deal with cakes and
things of that sorts.
We have honey as an edible glue,
and we have five letters.
The tricky part is that I
have to put them on backwards.
If we put them on and wrote Alvin
and we flipped the Kit Kat over,
it would say nivla.
That's not my name.
Give this a nice little glue,
damn, that's sticky, okay.
A-L-V-I, I.
If I do this correctly,
this should spell Alvin to the camera.
Does it spell Alvin?
The pan has now been lined
with our acetate strips,
which means it's time to get
this chocolate into this pan.
I'm going in.
Ooh, that's real nice.
I really like that.
Gotta make sure we get as
much of this out as we can.
This is not cheap.
My mom would yell at me.
This is gonna be my snack.
This is my personal bag now.
I've marked it.
Gotta make sure there's no air bubbles
so that we get all those nice corners.
Oh, I can save it.
A little wall almost caved in there.
Don't do that.
There you go, now we're good.
Don't you dare fall on me now.
Now we can go in with the wafer.
I'm gonna lay you down just like that.
Gotta get the edges.
Get you down in there
too, little buddy. Yeah.
This has set out for a little bit.
We're gonna get more chocolate in here.
Here we go.
Ooh, that's so nice. Damn.
Mm, this is great.
Pop those air bubbles real
quick, boop, boop, boop.
Little guys seem to be a little,
they're trying to escape
their chocolate prison,
so I wanna push them down like that.
I wanna hold these wafers
underwater, under chocolate,
until they stop moving and struggling.
That's dark. I'll see you guys in a bit.
(upbeat music)
So now I got one solid
ingot for the Kit Kat
and here we have a little contraption
that our culinary team was
nice enough to put together.
It has a foil and acetate set up,
which is where the Kit Kat is
going to be finally assembled.
So there are six pounds
of high quality chocolate in this bar.
We're just gonna try to
get this first one out.
Ooh, this is a tight fit in here.
Come out.
Oh, is that it?
That is not it.
Come on.
Ooh, oh man, that's pretty cool.
Oh, you know what this is like?
This is like when you
peel the thing on the TV
and you just go in there
and you get the, yeah.
And then if your parents
are Asian, like mine,
they never peel it off for some reason
'cause they think it
protects it, which it does,
but then it just looks ugly.
All right, and I gotta get
my name off of this thing.
Give me an A. A.
Give me an L.
L!
Not bad if I do say so myself.
As you can see the chocolate
right here is nice and shiny,
which means it has been tempered properly.
Damn. Pretty cool, huh?
Now I really got them bricks.
I'm gonna ask for some help
from our wonderful culinary team.
We're gonna make three of these.
My doctor's not gonna
be very happy with me,
but hey, this isn't making
it healthy, all right, so.
(playful music)
Now the idea is to get them all together
to be one whole Kit Kat, and
we're gonna use more chocolate.
Yeah, buddy.
All right, spread this
out a bit, ooh-hoo-hoo.
We've got a good base going.
This is gonna be one thick Kit Kat.
Yeah, get that stuff out.
Now we gotta get every single
one of these blocks in.
Ain't no way to do it,
but just to do it.
Ooh.
Brick, yeah. One. (chuckles)
Brick number two.
Ah, yes.
Looks like I gotta make some room.
I'll make it work.
I've done five seasons of this show.
Yeah, there we go.
It's gonna be one thick
ass Kit Kat I'm gonna say.
It has been about one hour.
This Kit Kat has been
setting in the fridge.
Fingers crossed 'cause
it's time to take it out.
Gonna take our walls.
♪ Gimme a piece of that big Kit Kat bar. ♪
So there's foil underneath the Kit Kat?
Let's see.
(tray clatters)
Nice. Physics.
Oops. Last piece.
We gotta do a little bit in this trimming,
(playful music)
also called snacking.
Approximately 70 years later,
this is a giant Kit Kat.
This weighs 30 pounds,
six pounds each bar.
And the base itself, also
six pounds of chocolate.
A culmination of many talented
individuals, culinary team,
making all these bars,
art team making this beautiful decoration,
camera and production team
making this look good on camera,
and me, I just ate chocolate all day.
Let's cut this thing and see what we got.
Come on.
Whoa.
Look at that.
Look at that cross section.
And for reference, this
is a normal Kit Kat.
This is what happens when
you give a guy like me
a lot of creative freedom and money.
Give me a break.
Woo! Cheers.
Oh, ours tastes good.
Ours taste quite different.
I do prefer ours because
well, one, we made it.
And two, it cost a lot more money.
I have a lot of enjoying to do,
so that being said, see you
guys in the next episode
where we're gonna continue to make it big.
This is really good.
(upbeat music)